lot of departures from snl have you guys
started to look at new folks and and you
know i don't think anyone's thought
about anything yet i think like
this is like our equivalent of an off
season you know and i think everyone
just like it's it's like every football
player is here in a less athletic way no
one's thinking about it at all yeah yeah
well you miss folks like pete and you
know of course yeah yeah i mean i i hope
i will still see them it's not like you
know i'm not suddenly not going to see
them but uh i'm
i'll miss them being around every day
it's nice when your friends are just in
the same building that you work in
by the way right now we really need
weekend update even looking at what's
going on in the country are you kind of
watching all this stuff and saying oh my
gosh i wish we were live there's always
stuff in the summer that you wish you
were back for but
based on the world i'm confident there's
going to be new things in the fall when
we get back this is your first time here
right this is my first time at this
event yeah how you feeling i'm feeling
pretty nervous
you know um
i'm just trying to have fun but it's
hard not to want to do well
you know you have a superhero in your
house did you get tips from the
superhero just more like outfit advice
you know um
really
i don't know i didn't really get many
tips um
get home right after this
why are you away for a whole week you
know like tips like that you know that
kind of stuff our babies almost won you
can't go back up for a week
things like that too leave me with the
baby and you're gonna pay for that by
the way cosmo turns one in august he
turns one coming up in a little bit
are you excited all right do you have a
big party plan
well the one is great because you could
just make up stuff that happened at the
party and he'll never know it didn't
happen i'll be like can you believe we
got billy eilish at your first through
third birthdays he'll never know it's
great
[Music]